Good afternoon.
Welcome to the
Faculty Forum Online,
a program of the MIT
Alumni Association
sponsored in part by the
MIT Professional Education.
I'm Judy Cole, the
executive vice president
and CEO of the MIT
Alumni Association,
and I will serve as
the moderator today.
If you want to ask
a question, please
use the box below the
live stream to submit it.
We will get to as
many as possible.
Our guest today is Institute
Professor John Harbison,
a Pulitzer Prize
winning composer
who joined MIT's music and
theater arts faculty in 1969.
Professor Harbison has written
for every type of concert
genre from opera to
intimate solo pieces
for the Metropolitan Opera,
for the Chicago Symphony,
for the Boston Symphony,
for New York Philharmonic,
and the chamber Music Society
of Lincoln Center, among others.
Here on campus,
Professor Harbison
founded MIT's
vocal jazz ensemble
in 2010, for which he served
as the coach and arranger.
He is a pianist with the faculty
jazz group Strength in Numbers.
In 2010, the Council
for the Arts at MIT
awarded Professor
Harbison the Kepes prize,
presented to a member
of the MIT community
who has demonstrated excellence
in the creative arts,
architecture, visual, and
performing arts and writing.
Professor Harbison, welcome.
Can you please start
by giving alumni
an update on your current
and upcoming projects?
I'll be glad to do that.
We have a special privilege
today in the broadcast--
live music, a piece I
wrote in this century--
early in this century--
from the collection called
The Violist's Notebook.
And Marcus Thompson,
Institute Professor,
my fabulous colleague, great
player, great musician,
is going to play this
very short piece.
It's entitled, I guess, or it's
dedicated to Marcus Thompson,
of all people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Marcus.
Thanks.
It makes a big
difference to have sound.
It does.
So now you're going to tell us
about your current projects.
My current projects are--
just having recently completed
a piece for a string quartet--
my sixth string quartet--
and sixth symphony
about two years ago.
Coming down the road, I'm
working on a very short opera.
Well actually, I work
at a slower pace.
So at this point,
I just finished
a piece called "Bag
of Tales", which
is codas-- short
pieces for pianists,
each dedicated to a
different pianist.
On Wednesday in New
York, all seven pianists
will show up and
play their movement.
This coming Wednesday?
Yeah.
Is that open to the public?
Yes, it is.
Oh, well tell us where
it's going to be.
Well, if I could
remember, I would.
National Sawdust, thank you.
Marcus knows.
Thank you.
All seven pianists
will be there.
They'll play a bunch
of my piano music,
and they will play
the seven pieces.
In fact, I've been
enlisted to play
one piece from a series called
"Leonard Stein Anagrams."
So I've been practicing
disproportionately
large amounts of time trying
to really learn that one minute
in order to be able to play in
a program with real pianists.
So thank you for that.
And a reminder to alumni,
please use the box
below the live stream
to ask questions
of Professor Harbison.
While we wait for the alumni
questions to be submitted,
I have a question
to start us off.
Do you consider
music at MIT to be
as some have called it
MIT's best kept secret?
Or is the secret
out of the bag now?
Well, we consider
it out of the bag.
I know Marcus and I have
talked about this often,
that we're still surprised
occasionally that people don't
know how much we're doing here.
It's partly because
MIT does so much.
And it's in such a
public way in science
and engineering
and urban planning.
It's very newsable subjects.
I think MIT students come
in here knowing pretty much
that there is a lot to offer.
And we know that
a lot of students
when they have a choice,
students that are qualified
for a number of
different places,
they will often tell
us they came here
because they knew about
what we are doing in music.
And doesn't some enormous
proportion of the students
take classes in
music or participate
in performance groups?
It's a very large number.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
And it seems to always attract
a very high, very well-prepared
group of students.
Students who really
know that music
is going to matter to them.
Most of them stay with
some aspect of our program
right on through.
So yeah, it's a very
satisfying place to work.
The commitment of a
student here at MIT--
I suppose it's in
every discipline-- is
a follow through.
We get such tremendous
commitment to every project.
Indeed.
So a second question
that I have is
alumni who is studying
under your tutelage
are now composers themselves
and professors of music
and professional musicians.
They are also probably engineers
and physicists as well.
Can you give us a few
examples of alumni working
in music who demonstrate the
breadth of careers in music
among our MIT alumni?
Well, there are a large number.
I very recently worked here
with Nina Young and Andrew
McPherson, both
of them extremely
distinguished young composers.
Rome Prize winner
in the case of Nina.
And Andrew McPherson--
both of them
Tanglewood Fellows, a very
high distinction also.
Really competitive with the best
young composers in the country.
And we expect that.
We expect that
from time to time.
We'll have very, very
highly successful musicians
go into the field.
They don't necessarily come
here with that firmly in mind,
but that often seems to
coalesce rather quickly.
Also in the world
of performance we've
had first chair players in major
symphonies, and we continue to.
It's going to be
always, shall we say,
an in-the-moment
change of career.
I would have to
really strain to think
of a student who
came here saying,
I'm going to be a
professional composer.
But in the case
of Nina Young, it
came over her after two
years of graduate school
in science, that the
musical impulse was too
strong not to continue.
Music is like that.
I mean, if you go into
it as a profession,
you do it partly because
it takes you over.
And that's happened
in a number of cases.
I'm sure that's the case.
So we have some alumni
questions coming in now,
so we should take those.
Dinan in Newton, Mass
asks, whom do you
consider to be your
greatest collaborator
either as a musician
or a composer?
I'm going to add to
that a librettos,
because I was wondering when
you said you were working
on an opera, whether or not--
who do you collaborate
with for the libretto?
And who else do you still
hope to collaborate with,
if you had your pick?
Well, I've done
three operas and I've
written librettos on my own.
I do that only for the sake of
collaboration or cooperation.
I don't want to have
to negotiate too
frequently about the detail.
But I've collaborated with some
great performers and composers
for sure.
James Levine I would have to
put very high on that list,
because he is such
an extraordinarily
complete musician.
He was so devoted to
a number of my pieces,
really, over 15, 20 years.
And I miss him
tremendously in that way
in that he's restricted his
conducting now pretty much
to opera at the Met.
I've worked with a number of
very distinguished singers,
because of course I've been
always a conductor of Baroque
music.
Lorraine Hunt Lieberson, who was
also a very close friend and I
miss tremendously as a person
of course as much as a singer.
And all those pianists who are
going to show up on Wednesday
at National Sawdust.
I mean, in the
course of a career,
I think those
collaborations are probably
the happiest part of it, that
music gets the composer out
of the studio for sure,
because you have to complete
the piece with a performer.
And I've worked with so many.
Herbert Blomstedt, who
was tremendously committed
to the idea that an
orchestra piece has
to come back to the public,
that one round is not enough.
And he brought back
my Second Symphony
I think in three seasons in San
Francisco when he was there.
It's hard to not leave
out great people--
Dawn Upshaw, of course, from
so early part in her career.
Still working with her
at Tanglewood in Bach,
coaching Standy Silva
in a similar way.
Someone I met very early.
So many of these people--
I always say this to
my Tanglewood Fellows--
these people that you meet at
the beginning of your life,
when you're all
just starting out--
for instance with Ursula
Oppens [INAUDIBLE]
we were starting in
a way, and we still
are working 30 years later.
You form a close bond
in those early years.
So who is left that you
have not yet collaborated
with that you aspire to?
Well, I guess I really am
waiting for another conductor
to make the commitment
that James Levine made
to me for 20 years.
It's a rare thing for a composer
to find that in today's world.
And I had that
huge good fortune.
And I guess if I dream in
terms or orchestra music,
I dream of finding again
that kind of a partnership.
Barbara Hannigan, who
is a great singer who
I've not worked with--
every time I hear
her I think, well,
maybe someday I
will have a chance.
But I'm happy also
with the great singers
that I do work with so
regularly at Emmanuel Music
and at Tanglewood.
Particularly, starting
careers with people.
One of the reasons I
loved my recent assignment
with this Bach Study Weeks at
Tanglewood that I've been doing
is those singers are
starting their lives.
And they're starting it
in the music of Bach,
which is I think the place
to start a life in music.
Good tip.
Mikhail in Cambridge
asks, what do you
think of the current
state of music publishing
digital copyrights
and their future?
Music publishing is
still very important,
but it's extremely
difficult and uphill.
And I honor and
cherish the people
that I'm so fortunate to
work with at Schirmer Music
Sales in New York.
We still need publishers,
but of course we can't really
protect any material anymore.
There's been some good sides
to that the audience perhaps
has been helped by streaming
and by direct access
to what we produce.
On the other hand, the
artistic side of music--
whether it be pop or concert--
is now on new footing towards
the public and towards usage.
And I think that we
have to try to emphasize
the upside of that, which
is that since people can
get and use things
with tremendous ease,
that we really hope that it
plays its role in audience
building, rather than really
regretting, as we all do
I'm sure, the loss of income.
I would imagine it would have
to, because there's simply
no substitute for seeing
a performance live.
Seeing it on a screen,
any sort of screen,
is never going to be--
you're not going to
have the same energy.
It is a tremendous difference.
And that may be one thing
that's being helped.
The New York
Philharmonic, which was
one of the toughest
on protecting
their broadcasts
and their sounds,
they were the
first big orchestra
to turn completely around.
And their audiences have grown.
So I think there
is something to it.
It can backfire.
I really feel sorry
for the Met losing
a lot in the house
because of the films.
I know they make a big
effort-- made a big effort
to reach a bigger public.
It's sad to go now some days
and see the direct effect
in the house.
And a lot of people
who like opera
are substituting film
for the live performance.
And of course, the
live performance
is a fantastic thing.
Oh, totally.
It cannot possibly be
duplicated by film.
When I lived closer to New
York, I used to go to the Met
on a regular basis.
So I appreciate
what you're saying.
There's really nothing
like going to an opera.
The amount of extraordinary
things that are happening.
And that's one thing
I think that's been--
in terms of communication
with the public,
that it's been
hard to get across.
Because people think
the films are really
the experience of opera.
And of course, if you
go into the opera house,
you realize they're not.
I remember from
years ago, someone
told me-- someone who was in
theater at Carnegie Mellon
University-- told me
that if someone doesn't
see live theater before the age
of something like five or 10,
it's highly likely
that they never will.
That's very true.
You need that exposure
early on in life.
Something happens to you
being in the presence
of the performer.
And there's something sonically
that cannot happen in any other
way.
Even the sound of voices.
Yeah, I absolutely believe that.
And I think that's
one of the things
that we in the artistic
community need to assert.
It's actually a
good byproduct, I
guess, in both the
pop and concert world
that it's become more
necessary to bring
the public into the
house, because we don't
have other income sources.
Particularly in the
pop world, they've
now discovered that they must
get out in front of the public.
I would say, bring the
public into the house
with their children.
Which is better.
It's actually better.
Todd in Boston asks, you have
said of the venues on campus
that it is like being
a great football
institution with small dressing
rooms in a small stadium.
Do you see that
improving any time soon?
Well, we do have a real issue
about that in our performance
spaces.
And it's been difficult
at the hiring level when
we show a candidate
for a position
here what the
performance spaces are,
we've had people turn us down.
And of course, we
have great people here
who are struggling to make
a great program with spaces
that are not competitive.
And also, some of us
who go out to a number
of other institutions to
perform or to take part
in their programs,
we are struck by how
really below standard
MIT is in the arts.
And we've made our case, and
we're continuing to make it.
Kresge is a great building.
Famous for good reasons,
and the chapel as well.
But they were not built
for the performance
of music, or for theater
performances, for that matter.
They've been pressed into
service for 70 years.
And it's not the fault
of the architect,
because he did what
he was asked to do,
which is to make a forum
for speech, for lecture.
So the other spaces are
makeshift and temporary,
and we regard them as such,
and we do great work in them.
And our students do great work.
But I think we are waiting.
Well, I understand what you're
saying there too, because when
you try to serve too
many purposes at one time
or in one facility,
you serve none of them
as well as could be hoped.
I think Kresge was built
with the expectation
that other venues
would take up--
Would follow.
--as specialists.
Because Kresge, I love it.
I love it more and more.
I think its brilliance as
a building doesn't fade.
But its inadequacies for many
of the things that has to do
remain.
So going back to
what we were just
talking about in the
previous question, Nathan
in Springfield,
Massachusetts asks,
can you talk about how you
first got into classical music,
and how you advise parents
to engender that interest
in their children?
Well, that was it.
My parents played on the
piano, and we had a phonograph.
And I soon learned to pick
out things I wanted to hear.
And particularly,
my father playing
versions of Bach
[INAUDIBLE] on the piano.
That was what got me
going, and playing jazz.
He was-- I'd not say
a real jazz player,
but he played the standards.
And I learned a lot of those
tunes when I was just a kid.
And I think that's where--
in the home is where it happens.
Some people get it just
by foraging around.
It's hard to do that in a
way, because radio is now
playing a role that it once
played in bringing music
to kids, or at least in terms
of bringing concert music
and jazz and more
esoteric kinds of music.
So I think the parents, even if
they are not musicians or not
particular practitioners
at all, if they can just
show children where it is.
How do you find it?
Expose them to it,
and let them hear it.
Because that's more the
parents than the schools now.
Schools unfortunately took
quite a hit a long time
ago in terms of the arts.
And so it's really at home.
And then the
wonderful channels--
there are always channels.
Places where people can learn
to really become effective
in these various arts.
These wonderful youth
orchestras in so many cities,
which are incredibly
spirited environments,
and incredibly powerful
in terms of their effect
on the lives of young musicians.
Indeed.
So moving along,
Andrew in Charlotte
says, can you talk about
a student's piece of music
that you loved so much that
you listen to it often?
Yeah, I can.
Just kind of off the top of
my head, my recent tangle
with students, we choose them--
we used to choose them perhaps
for more responsible reasons
than we came to.
But now when we do
auditions-- we have 100, 120--
we would listen to them,
we would bring it down
to about 20, and we
would pick the six
that we wanted to listen to for
eight weeks, just as members
of the crowd, really.
And in that way, Juri Seo's
piano sonata, I love it.
I mean, it's crazily
adventurous and peculiar.
I can remember
quite a few pieces--
certain pieces of Helen Grime,
a young British composer
who came to us about eight
years ago at Tanglewood.
Yeah, of course I grew
up on these pieces,
because that's
why we chose them.
We wanted to hear
more of what they did.
And I think that
finding that criteria
was a freeing thing
for us as instructors,
as well as I think just
thinking about the profession.
What criteria were you
trying to use before you
came to that conclusion?
We were trying to in a
way predict something
about these applicants.
Predict success of some sort.
Trying to predict a line
of development we've seen.
But rather than just being
almost kind of pleasure hounds,
of what are they
able to do now, that
proved to be a better vector.
I can see why.
So Bonnie in Washington says,
as a former student of yours,
I'm in awe of all you've done
with your vast repertoire
and compositions in
the past 20-plus years
since I took your class.
Given the recent
political environment,
including announcements to
consider defunding NEA National
Endowment for the
Humanities, how
do you feel
opportunities will be
impacted with regard to moving
music and the arts forward?
Well, we've never for
many, many decades
depended on government
support in the arts.
The very fact they've
announced again
and we're going
to defund the arts
is just a joke, because
compared to other countries that
are serious about this,
we're not in the game.
So really what it's about
is these old systems
that we've always had, which
is really private patronage.
And we need to
embrace and celebrate
people who are game enough
and adventurous enough
to participate in that.
It can be an exciting
and stimulating thing
for people to be
interested enough
in the arts to want to
really step up and make
sure they keep going.
And I'm encouraged that
there's a lot of signs
of vitality within that system.
We can't look to any
other systems of the kind
that Germany and France and
England have made work so well.
We're just not in
that frame of mind.
They look at our
tradition-- it really
is a tradition of
philanthropy in the arts-- as
somehow corrupt.
But I look at the government
system over there as corrupt.
It's all a social network, which
produces hopefully occasionally
some really worthy, good things.
I'm just writing a piece
for Chanticleer, which
is a vocal group in California.
Now, Chanticleer has existed
for now probably 30, 40 years,
as an all-male choir.
An unlikely thing, but supported
locally from the San Francisco
area with amazing following.
And by concert music
standards, they're
a really popular audience.
This is doable.
So I just read the other day
the big announcement, well,
we're not going to
fund the arts anymore.
Well, that's just
completely mirrors.
You're not funding it now.
That's complete nonsense.
So Maxine in Boston says,
I majored in engineering,
but I minored in music
at MIT, and I loved it.
I am a classically
trained pianist.
Are there musical
groups available
for alumni like me to join?
Yes, actually I can't
give specific references,
but I know in two
cities in San Francisco
and in Minneapolis there were
MIT music network groups.
So she's here in Boston.
Do we have one in Boston
that you're aware of?
Oh, there must be one in Boston.
Informally, the
Longwood Orchestra
has long been a kind
of MIT-inhabited group.
A lot of people who
are premeds here
who have gone and
keep on playing.
There must be in Boston.
There are a lot of smaller
musical groups in Boston,
it seems.
I am always seeing announcements
about their concerts.
But I was always
impressed by the vitality
of the Sanfrancisco
MIT musical network.
It seemed to go
generation to generation.
Jeevan in Miami asks an
interesting question.
Where does inspiration
come from for you?
Do you see music and art as
more in the act of creating
or in the act of performing?
Well--
How do you tease
those apart, actually?
I think what I've
learned about inspiration
is that you don't disdain
even the most fragmentary sort
of indication of a direction.
I learned to write
down so I remember
even little fragments that
seemed to have no potential.
Because I work always on
the basis of sending out
a runner if I have anything
like a melody or a chord
that will run out ahead
and show direction.
I just learned to value the
unconscious and the things that
don't seem to be
potentially useful.
I get as much out of the
not potentially useful
as the things that I'm
quite sure about right away.
And I think that
pragmatism is something
that I try to suggest to
the Tanglewood Fellows I
teach who are so highly gifted.
But that's where the
independent side creeps in,
is if you begin to respect
the things that don't fit.
That makes a lot of sense.
Ken in Chicago
says, can you talk
about a commission
you've turned down
or work you have
abandoned, something
that has challenged you
are still haunts you
for leaving behind?
Well, I've turned down a
couple that I eventually
did that I feel lucky
that I changed my mind.
Why did you turn
them down initially,
and what turned you around?
I turned down the commission
from the Chicago Consulate
of the State of Israel
for the 50th anniversary
of the establishment of
Israel, which eventually turned
into a piece called
"Four Psalms",
which I think is one
of my best pieces.
I turned it down for
a number of reasons.
I was pressing towards
completing opera
at Great Gatsby.
I didn't think I had time.
And I was a little
worried that they
had chosen a non-Jewish composer
for this really big commission,
though the commissioning
body seemed
quite confident that that's
what they wanted to do.
And I called the Consul
General when I changed my mind.
I said, I'm just haunted.
It was a couple of months later.
Is there any chance I
could still get into this?
He said, well, yes, it's awkward
and shame on you, and so forth.
But I felt incredibly
fortunate to get back
into the project, because
it had haunted me.
I thought, this
was an opportunity
first of all for study.
Sometimes the research
behind a piece
is as valuable a part of
the experience as anything,
that you have to
learn so much to just
be able to grasp what
the piece could be about.
And in that case my studying--
I studied very beginning Hebrew.
I knew I wanted to work
in Hebrew, some of it.
And I went to Israel for a
two or three week period.
It was an incredibly
irreplaceable enlargement
of my experience.
And I think that's
the kind of thing--
I guess about the
things I've turned down,
I usually try to say, well,
it wasn't salvageable.
I don't look back on that.
But more than that time,
I've been haunted and been
able to save the project.
Well, the fact that
ultimately came around
says to me that it
was meant to be.
Yeah, I don't know.
It meant that the group--
which I discovered later--
the commissioning group in
Chicago were very engaged.
In fact, when I submitted
my text, every one of them--
every element of the
text was objected to
by the commissioners.
And eventually, the Consul
General stepped in and said,
we hired this
composer, and we better
respect what he wants to do.
And so I did it,
and I'm really--
I hope that piece makes a few
more appearances, because I
think [? unsadly ?] enough,
it's still as relevant
now as it was a long time ago.
Another alumnus question.
Jim in St. Louis
says, regarding radio,
I hear less and
less classical music
on the radio where I
live, and have resorted
to podcasts and YouTube.
But I'm my own DJ there.
What else do you
recommend for keeping
abreast of contemporary
composers online or on air?
Yeah, and radio
is a big loss now.
We learned so much about what
is going on in music from radio,
going way back to
when I was very young.
And I got my job as a
composer in residence
in Pittsburgh symphony
because of radio.
A piece of mine came on
Andre Previn's car radio,
and he pulled off to
the side of the road
and waited to get an ID.
And I wound up
going to Pittsburgh.
And that was when
radio was still
a life force in
all kinds of music,
and even jazz has lost a huge
amount of ground on radio.
So I think the
substitute source is
the websites of composers of all
kinds, both pop and in concert,
where sometimes entire
pieces are available.
Publishers of composers, that's
become the substitute venue
for finding out about music.
And sadly, you have to kind of
know what you're looking for.
What about the websites of some
of the famous classical music
stations in Boston and New
York and other major cities,
like WGBH?
Yeah, I think that's helpful.
But it's not nearly as
good as what we did have,
which was the ideas of
some programmer who really
put together a broadcast.
I'd say that the
undergraduate radio
stations, the college
radio stations,
are doing best,
certainly in this city.
HRB still hangs in well
at Harvard Emerson.
That's our best hope,
because there you have
an enterprising junior who--
a couple of years ago I
heard a great broadcast
on the bass player Ray
Brown by a jazz hound
who knew everything Ray
Brown ever recorded.
And they get an hour and
put on a great broadcast.
That still can happen, because
so much initiative there.
But in general, we don't have--
most radio is very little
dedicated to music of any kind.
Toby in Singapore says,
I am grateful to you
for being my chamber
music professor
when I played cello at MIT.
My six-year-old son is
now learning about music
from one of your composition
students John Sharpley.
Indeed.
Can you talk about when
you developed your interest
in composition, and how you
were encouraged to develop
your musical writing style?
Well, I started young.
A lot of composers do.
And I had written pieces
at a very, very small age,
like five, six, seven years old.
And I had a teacher
in high school
who was my piano teacher,
but she didn't like
the way I played the piano.
I was already a
jazz player, and she
didn't want to listen to
me swinging Beethoven.
So she looked at my pieces then.
And so I got a lot of support
just by saying, here it is.
I'm doing this.
And I had the advantage of
some quite interested teachers.
I think again, this
is a good situation
where the parents and
children can work together
at that first stage.
Over and over as I look at
biographies of composers
who turned into really
productive practitioners,
a high percentage had
that parent at the start,
right in the midst of it.
And really, that kind of
early help, first of all,
it makes you feel less weird.
Because socially, those kinds of
interests are hard to fit into.
They tend not to be
the mainstream fad
kinds of interests.
Indeed I regretted
for many years,
once I was invited to play
in the high school assembly.
And they said, play anything
you want for high school.
So I played the pieces
I was working on,
which were the Schoenberg
Piano pieces Opus 11.
And all the girls I was
interested in, they ran away.
And my friends didn't invite
me out for a long time.
And I was I guess very naive.
I thought, this is
interesting to me.
But because one is as a young
musician, even a jazzer now,
is somewhat isolated by
the intensity of what
they're doing, that parental
support is very helpful--
parental and teacher
support, I guess,
because you do take a
different social track.
I think that's probably
true of any passion
that a student pursues as
intensely as most of our MIT
students pursue their passions.
Absolutely.
That's what I see in them.
And that may be what
they find in each other
when they come here.
I see that in MIT students.
I recognize it.
And some of them have been
through socially awkward high
school experiences
because they're so
wrapped up in something.
And for me, it was
concert music, which
was a fairly rare passion.
The jazz helped, but
jazz already by that time
was becoming another
form of rather
specialized appreciation.
So yes, it was great in
college to meet some more
people that were like that.
And I think MIT is an
unbelievable meeting
place for people who've been
nurturing extraordinary project
on their own.
Jill in Brookline says,
speaking of Kresge,
it was built with a
pipe organ built in.
So perhaps the design for music
was just not up to the goals.
Well, the pipe organ was part
of the original commission.
And it was because it was being
envisioned as a public events
site for MIT.
The pipe organ makes me sad to
hear our questioner mention it,
because of course it
was a major instrument,
as was the one in the chapel.
Both are in disrepair.
And organ repair
is so expensive,
it's probably far down
on the to-do list.
But the reason for that great
Kresge organ being put there
was that the sort of
great state occasions that
are part of a big university
were going to occur there.
You need triumphal music.
Now there isn't much on
that organ that we can use.
And both the MIT
organs are awaiting
a very unusual
and perhaps crazed
kind of benefactor, a deeply
organ-loving benefactor.
Because they are among the
great instruments in the city.
And of course at this
point, they're unheard.
But they speak of another
era of university life,
where I guess that kind
of ceremonial conclave
is less frequent.
But the Kresgy organ, before
I was a faculty member here,
I heard it.
And it was one of the big
grand organs of the region.
Mason in Dartmouth,
New Hampshire says,
your work testifies to
your love of poetry, e.g.
The arrangement of Louis
Gluck's The Seven Ages.
Can you tell us more about
how you incorporate poetry
into your process
when composing?
That's my main ancillary reading
is poetry, more than novels.
And I do like short stories,
but novel reading, it's too time
spanned a thing for me.
Poetry I read all the time.
And I get the Poetry A Day thing
from the Poetry Foundation,
and I get Poetry Magazine.
I'm like someone who comes
into the Grolier bookstore,
and they say, you don't
seem to be a poet.
What are you doing here?
And poetry means a
lot, because it sort of
brings in the kind of world I
want to be in when I'm working.
And I have felt
the collaboration
of poets dead or alive to be a
huge changing force in my life.
In the Louis Gluck case,
I've had the great fortune
of after setting her,
becoming a friend of hers,
and really
understanding something
about her off-work world,
which is meaningful to me,
and for which I feel kinship.
Wow.
Larry in Scituate, Mass
says, Lloyd Schwartz
called Gabriella
Diaz's performance
if your "For Violin
Alone" in December one
of the highlights of the year.
What are your impressions
of how this piece has
been interpreted?
Well, that was a very
wonderful occasion for me.
That piece has a
strange history.
I'm not quite sure why, but
the commissioner of the piece,
Jennifer Koh-- a very
distinguished violinist--
played it four times, never
making a recording of it
or really commenting
on the piece.
So I had never really
heard the piece
until two friends, Daniel
Stepner and Gabby Diaz,
both did the piece this season.
And so that's my
first acquaintance
with the piece by then
four or five years back.
I was tremendously glad
that both of those players
took the piece on.
Because it's a large piece, and
it's a big chunk of one's life.
When you're a composer,
when you haven't
met the piece in the
real in the room,
you don't have a complete
relationship to it.
I mean, obviously you should
know what you did more or less.
But you don't have the
rest of the equation,
like what happens when
it's in a room with people.
I used to be annoyed when
a couple of my colleagues--
older, in those days, my
experienced colleagues-- said
you listen to the way
people are breathing when
your piece is being played.
You listen to the coughs.
These are all indicative
of how you are holding them
for that amount of time.
I didn't take it
seriously at the time.
I do now.
And that's part of
what completes a piece.
And certainly, that
occasion with Gabby
playing and also within Dan
a few weeks before that,
I managed to get that last
sort of lap with that piece.
A little bit of
relaxation occurred too,
because you evaluate sort
of how close does it come up
to what you were trying to do?
Yeah, I can see
where the creation
of a piece, the
composition of a piece,
and then the performance of the
piece or sort of intricately
intertwined in terms
of that whole process.
But the performance is
the other end of it.
And as much as we don't worry
about that when we're writing
that piece-- because that would
be inhibiting in terms of what
you want to try in the piece--
at the point when it's done,
you're waiting for a circle
to close.
So at the grave risk of
running over time a little bit,
we are going to take one
last question from Don,
class of '61, Boothbay, Maine.
He says, I'm an old grad
who is writing music--
chamber music, choral music,
songs, and five operas.
It would be marvelous
to hear some
of my work performed in Kresge.
Is there any chance of that?
Well, you do what composers
do when you write pieces.
You try to get
immediate colleagues who
you can trust to
really work on them
and to provide some sonic
material that you can send out.
Or you can send out scores.
People are not as energetic
at really studying scores
as they once were, because
the sound material is easier
to get at.
But that's what
composers all do.
And what I always say to--
this is very obviously a
veteran musician here--
what I would say to
the young composers
is that you have to get
a community around you,
a few people who will do
some work on the pieces,
so that you can make that
equation we were just
talking about.
And it's from that base
that you expand outwards.
And it would seem that
this questioner must
have someone or some
people around who will say,
I'll take this piece.
I'll learn it.
We'll get a really
good version of it,
and we'll get people interested.
Do composers pitch directly to
performance groups sometimes?
They do.
And I find that
the most effective
is the fewer people you're
pitching to, the better.
The easier it is to sell them.
Well, what I was
thinking is, look up
some of the student
groups on campus.
Go to a student group and
see if they'll take it on.
Absolutely.
And of course, here at MIT with
some of the student ensembles,
we do compositions by
their colleagues, which
is the really logical equation.
But I think of the people
that I gave pieces to
or that asked for pieces
when I was just starting out,
Ursula Oppens, And I'm
still with people like that.
Bob Levine.
It's been-- how many?
50 years.
But it still works.
Well, that's terrific.
Thank you so much,
John, on behalf
of the MIT Alumni Association
for joining us here today.
This has been a
terrific conversation.
And thanks to the alumni for
tuning in for the questions,
and for the questions.
If we did not get
to your question,
we will pass it on to Professor
Harbison after the webcast.
And you can also share other
reactions or further questions
using hashtag #MITBetterWorld.
Archived past
Faculty Forums Online
can be viewed by visiting the
Learn section of the Alumni
Association website.
Please join us again
later this week
for another session of
Faculty Forum Online.